i did an american voice for a film
the one that like uh charlie critical
was in oh yeah yeah yeah i was like the
kill
but i wasn't credited you weren't
credited i forgot to i think they forgot
so yeah i like the voice of of the like
killer yeah
yeah and it's like this like really
raspy uh deep like
scary voice like an american accent and
they were like we wanted to do
and i was so i remember we were having i
was having a call with the people who
were making this film
and they were telling me all about this
role and then this is going on for like
half an hour and they mentioned
oh um yeah he's american and then at the
end of it i was like so
like the accent i don't know if you
noticed i'm not married
so what do you want me to do and they're
like well he is an american so could you
do american and i'm like i can
but it won't be good right yeah so i did
it i feel that your
american accent is probably better than
most right because i feel i don't know
when i do deep voices it's
easier because that the mouth shape is
easier but it's still [ __ ]
but i feel like you would laugh at me
but i feel like a lot of like british
actors for instance are usually pretty
good at nailing the american accent
there are so many british or just like
you know
uh hackers not from america that you
don't know aren't from america until
it's like outed but then
you switch you swap to the other way
around with american americans doing
like british accents yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
cause like how many people think you
know like if they watch like batman for
instance right like
christian bale and gary aldman yeah both
not american
christian bales welsh yeah christian
right
yeah i'm pretty sure gary oldman is very
british yeah so it's like it's just
incredible to think that like a lot of
people just don't know like chris
chris hemsworth as well it's like chris
the most [ __ ] aussie guy i've ever
seen he nails the american accent yeah
yeah
i think yeah because they teach the
trained british actors different to
american yeah
what different ways of learning acting
so i think that has a lot to do with it
because like british are more focused on
like stage acting right yeah
learning training yeah being more
classically trained
yeah so it's a bit different i don't
know yeah and i also feel like if you're
going to acting you kind of
need to learn how to do an american
accent that's because that's where most
films are made right you know but it's
not the same the other way around so you
know
hating american accents for stuff you
always have to do it for things it sucks
i hate it
just let me use my british accent
[Laughter]
the one time where i was like oh i might
have a chance is like uh what was it
the the free uh like what was the movie
they spoke english in it right and it
was like terrible yeah but they hired
non-australian actors
and acts and like actresses so i'm like
yeah
i'm right here i'm right here right here
people right here what is it just hit up
that [ __ ] side in school
go through the contact